[Music]
hey y'all
what the hell day is it today it's
monday monday yeah that's right monday
we're doing a good one
um it's called uh the accountant yeah we
got it right here
yeah
louis senate yeah
louie always sends good movies he does
yeah he said this one and he sent the
steel book of uh karate kids
it's coming from louie then i know it's
some good [ __ ] he's got a good taste he
does have good dates and movies now
louie
i think you may have sent me some other
ones that i haven't gotten to yet
matter of fact if anybody has sent us
movies
and we haven't reviewed them
drop drop yeah tell me because sometimes
i forget like what i get yeah because i
still got them but
during the move
they got packed in all with my regular
ones and i i don't know which ones i've
seen and haven't seen anymore
so i need a list of the ones you guys
set that that we didn't review so i can
pull them out and put them in line so i
can line them up and
i can think of one that um that somebody
said it might have been louie but i
can't remember uh was sexy beast which
i've actually seen before but you've
never seen it yeah i haven't seen it yet
and that's uh that's one yeah i really
liked it but um yeah i haven't seen it
for a long time but i that was
definitely one that i remember that we
never got around to remember
sophie sent that oh yeah maybe she did
so if you sent that i can't remember
like i said it was a long time ago when
we just
and like i said when we moved it kind of
everything got moved around and yeah we
used to have them all like in a pile
like separate and i got sent collateral
twice
that's right with uh tom cruise and we
tried to watch it twice and couldn't get
five minutes into it he decided
there's something about the beginning
we'll have to try again sometime yeah
because so many people like this movie
and i'm like well there has to be a
reason why so many people like it it's
just i'm just i don't know if i'm just
never in the right mood to watch it or
something like man this is slow
it's not even that i'm not even sure i
can't put my finger on what it is
something about the tone of the first
five or ten minutes of that movie it's
like i don't want to see this one and
i'll move it back in the line but it's
supposed to be a good movie i just i
just got to let it play yeah
but yeah this particular movie i
actually this came back this came out
back in 2016
and i actually hadn't heard about it i
think that was the same year wasn't that
the same year the batman vs superman
came out i don't remember
uh batman versus superman wasn't that
the same year that that came out i think
it wasn't ben affleck in that too but um
yeah so this came out in 2016
and i had never heard of it even though
it was actually pretty financially
successful uh made 155 million dollars
on only 44 million budget
so this is basically
it's sold as an action thriller which i
guess it kind of is
um but it's kind of like a character
study too and almost like a financial
mystery
i don't know there's a lot of stuff
going on in this
kind of reminds me of that movie the
professional where you got like a guy
who's [ __ ]
almost like an assassin or a hit man
type of guy but he's weird
but he's weird yeah and this is a guy
about a guy who is an accountant
but he's also ex-military and his dad
was ex-military and he's
had a bunch of training and stuff
and he's an accountant for all these
organized crime syndicates
but he's also um a mathematical genius
he's got autism
so his dad kind of like
trained him so well that the autism
didn't much matter i guess he could even
go into the military
and uh he went goes to prison too
and learned stuff in prison and
anyway uh once he was out he
he got involved with this
it's
it's kind of complicated i was gonna say
this is this is definitely a movie i
actually really liked this a great deal
um but it definitely is one that you
have to pay close attention to because
the plot has a lot of moving parts
yeah and the movie uh thankfully does
not spell a lot of things out for you
you got to figure it out um you kind of
have to figure things out as it goes
along and it jumps back and forth in
time without really
telegraphing that or without really like
telling you john doll's in it too that's
right which i like him he does a good
job i think it was great as shane and
[ __ ] walking dead
did good as the punisher too even though
the writing on the punisher is not good
but he does a great job with what they
give him he's just too soft but [ __ ]
he was he [ __ ] nailed the punisher in
fighting
daredevil season two that's that was the
punisher the punisher series
uh
he's just too sane the punisher's
supposed to be just [ __ ] mean you
know that's what
but uh he's in this movie he plays a
basically a
guy who owns a
a private security company
uh for bad guys basically
well he'll work for anybody or for
anybody that will pay him
so like kind of a mercenary yeah he's
also just a torpedo if you've been
[ __ ] over your company your company
wants you to stop stealing money they'll
they'll send him after you he'll beat
you up scare the [ __ ] out of you and
possibly kill you he does that too so
he's kind of like a hit man also
yeah so like i said there's a lot of
stuff going on because
i mean the main kind of narrative is
mostly about ben affleck's character
whose
name is christopher wolf although that's
an alias like you don't i don't even
think you do you ever find out what his
actual real name is i don't know i think
they do say at some point but um he goes
by different aliases usually uh
different mathematicians
because so you kind of get into his
backstory but then there's also this
other thing
where
uh jk simmons that actor he works for
the treasury department yeah
and he kind of blackmails this woman
into
tracking him down because nobody knows
who this ben affleck well like who he is
they know that he's just known as the
accountant
and he works for
again anybody that will pay him like
he'll work for like terrorists or
extremist groups or anything like that
anybody that needs the services of an
accountant like somebody's you know
stealing money from them or something
like that so he has to come in and like
look at their books and figure it out
and because he has autism and he's like
a mathematical genius he's really really
good at it and he can like pick up
[ __ ] that other people would miss so
he's kind of become really really well
known in really high up criminal circles
as the dude that's gonna like figure out
your [ __ ] for you and so he's been
photographed like with all of these kind
of like high up criminal dudes and so
the treasury department is like really
really after him they don't know with
his identity they just see him in all
these pictures so there's also that
parallel story
of uh the treasury department trying to
like figure out the mystery of who this
guy is there's also a little bit of a
romantic subplot i don't know if i'd go
that far to say but there is a little
bit of that yeah there's a little bit of
that in there um but not like in a
cheesy like rom kind of way um but yeah
so what has been a lot of interest yeah
like what ends up happening is he
actually even though he usually works
for criminals he actually gets a gig
where supposedly he's working for a
legit company which is like a robotics
uh company for people that have had
limbs removed and whatnot
uh run by john lithgow
and uh
somebody has found a discrepancy this uh
you know woman that works there who's
played by uh anna kendrick and she
has found some kind of discrepancy so
they bring him in because his reputation
precedes him and he finds the
discrepancy and then it turns out that
that kind of puts a target on his back
and also uh the woman that initially
found the discrepancy and they kind of
have
it's i don't know they kind of like
start developing a little bit of a
relationship but because he has autism
and he can't really
relate to people in any particular way
even though he has like trained to be
somewhat
social but not really all that social um
but she kind of yeah he can fake it a
little bit uh but he still comes across
as very blunt and very weird and like
they have a thing where
she makes some kind of uh she makes some
kind of joke about the college that she
went to right where oh she says where
fun goes to die and he's like he doesn't
understand like that that's a joke or
what she's talking about um he's like
why why does fun go to tyler you know
what i mean so i thought it was like a
pretty good this is essentially it's
funny that you brought up daredevil
because this is kind of a similar thing
where they're almost attempting to make
it's not like a superhero story but
they're almost attempting to make like a
badass action hero out of somebody that
has
you know what would have in the past
been called a quote-unquote handicap you
know what i mean just like daredevil and
he's blind but
but his blindness actually becomes
something that's sort of like a
superpower and i kind of feel like they
did that a little bit with this too but
in a more like realistic yeah but he's a
criminal he is yeah so that's what i was
going to say he's kind of more like the
professional yeah because you know he
was that guy was mentally handicapped he
was the hit man the criminal but he was
also kind of like a superhero in a way
trying to save that girl
which
makes you wonder if he had a
relationship with this girl she said
they did but then it looked like she was
fantasizing about it but that was a good
movie anyway man we'll have to do that
one at some point too i haven't seen
that for years and i remember liking
that movie a lot yeah that was a little
bitty what's her name [ __ ] yeah
that's right that little what's that
woman's name yeah yeah i know uh
yeah natalie bartman it was like a yeah
it was a baby now she's like an 11 year
old not like a baby baby but she's like
11 12 maybe yeah natalie portman
probably 11.
yeah she played the little the girl that
he saved
and he saved her from getting hit huh
i think i just i can't remember it's
been like so long since kind of like a
reversal of the story gloria which i
want to do that one
about the gangster chick oh yeah there's
a little boy live next door yeah that's
right yeah hugo said i liked this movie
hey you don't get batman versus punisher
every day
yeah exactly so uh so yeah so i do kind
of like
i just i don't know there was a lot that
i really really liked about this it's
kind of as i said an original take on i
saw this other review of it and they
said it's almost like a beautiful mind
meets the board identity which uh you
know i thought that was kind of yeah
like using something that you know would
be kind of but the thing about it is
that it's not just the fact that he's
autistic or he's a mathematical genius
and can go through like because he goes
through like years and years and years
of this company's books like in one
night and finds all these little
discrepancies and stuff which no one's
been able to do and so it's not only
that he can do that but the fact that
they do all these flashbacks and because
you know they they go back to i guess it
was like the 80s right
and they go back to like this
neurological place where he was at when
he was a kid
and his dad who was very he was like a
psyops guy and he's just kind of like i
don't think that we should put the kid
in like an institute and i don't think
that we should you know even though he
has like all these like heightened
sensitivities to like noise and stuff
like that he's like i think we should go
the opposite direction and like do like
over stimulation so that he gets used to
it because the world isn't gonna you
know accommodate him and all this other
kind of stuff so
he so he did all that kind of stuff like
his dad did and his dad had him trained
at like martial arts and like jakarta
and he had like
he would take him to like you know
bullies and stuff would pick on him
because he was weird and that he would
just his dad would take him and she's
like no go beat all those bully's asses
and so he so he like kind of like quote
unquote toughened him up so that's sort
of why and he's like super super into
guns and he has like pretty much all the
money that he could ever want although a
lot of it seems like it's in like gold
and paintings and stuff like that yeah
he's got some badass guns but yeah he's
got like a whole like in his airstream
trailer where he goes from place to
place because like i said he can't
really
settle down anywhere he can't really
have an identity anywhere because he
works for like the highest like criminal
organizations in the world he had so
much money they pay him in all these
guns sometimes
when he abandoned his main house which
is just like a normal looking house like
in a
middle middle class [ __ ]
kind of neighborhood you know kind of
country middle class
and he left behind guns and he left
behind a damn general electric minigun
and let go he's [ __ ] he left behind
[ __ ] because he couldn't take it with
him
just he had a gun i mean yeah he had a
[ __ ] good [ __ ] look like some kind
of barrett 50 i don't think it was a
barrett it was a it was another was 50
caliber semi-auto rifles
i don't think it was a barrett though
you use that blue dude's [ __ ] head
off with it he's real good with guns
yeah well like i said that's somebody
that i mean this seemed like
a fairly accurate portrayal of somebody
with uh with high functioning autism and
that's something that a lot of autistic
uh
men have particularly is they're very
very uh into
machines or they're like laser focused
on one so that like totally tracks they
know everything about one subject they
would know everything about like one
thing yeah uh you know so he knows a lot
about guns and a lot about math but not
so much about a bunch of other stuff
people about people so in some of the
ways it's like it's not a comedy that
but it does have like some kind of funny
touches in it just the way that people
react to him and the way he's because he
just comes across as like just very
blunt he had this trailer that he could
he could leave with it was like one of
those damn 1950s yeah like airstream
airstream types all
um
polished aluminum on the outside and
inside it was all wood high class [ __ ]
he had [ __ ] red was in there and
[ __ ]
jackson pollock paintings up on the
ceiling yeah
classy [ __ ] in there that drawers full
of gold bars
and [ __ ] a lot of high-end [ __ ]
guns and armor he had like he had a
[ __ ] armory room he walked in there
and there was a [ __ ] all of his
[ __ ] [ __ ] up in racks with his
[ __ ] body armor and it was it was a
cool concept i would love to have
something like that that's what should i
build
yeah that definitely seemed like
something yeah well i just kind of liked
it because he could leave at any moment
he could just leave and have everything
and he'd have a classy pad wherever he
went yeah but he didn't really he was
kind of appreciating it but i don't
think he realized how hot it was
yeah because yeah he was just kind of
like he was just doing what he wanted to
do like and it was funny too because he
has like drawers full of gold bars and
all the guns and stuff like that and
then he has drawers full of like all the
old like action comics yeah actually
like and action comic number one was
superman yeah and he treated it exactly
the same as you would treat a gold bar
which i guess you probably should
because it's probably worth something i
think it's worth over a million of it
yeah so but yeah so he had all that kind
of stuff too and it's just like you said
maybe like intellectually he knew that
it was odd but yeah like when that when
his uh that friend of his what was her
character named dana dana yeah when she
came over because he was trying to
protect her because now you know she was
going to get shot too because of the
accounting thing that she uncovered and
she comes into the into this airstream
and she's like what the [ __ ]
it's like exactly because she just
thought he was like some nerdy
yeah you know because he just seems like
a nerdy awkward dude but i like that he
doesn't overplay it yeah you know what i
mean because i do
feel like sometimes uh you know some
actors if they have to play somebody
that has some kind of you know
neurological disorder or whatever
um i kind of feel like they err on the
side of maybe going too far with it but
ben affleck i think did a good job in
this he's very he has a very flat affect
um he's not it's not played it's i don't
want to say it's not played for laughs i
mean he does say some funny [ __ ] but
they're not like it's not like making
fun of him he had a motorcycle too i
think it was either in that trailer or
in the garage i don't remember if he
left it behind it was uh one of those
uh one i think a confederate wraith
i think it was i think it's called a
wraith or a banshee
had that damn carbon fiber springer
front end on it
[ __ ] super expensive basically hand
built motorcycle you had one of those
was that in the trailer or was that in
the garage
and
well that's the thing like after he took
off yeah after that one after he uh
saved dana and he had to like
split because they were both like uh you
know gonna get assassinated
um so he abandoned his house and then
the you know the feds came and like went
to the house and he had left a bunch of
stuff in there and i think that's where
it was like when they went into the
garage i think if i remember correctly
that motorcycle well you couldn't take
it i mean
i guess maybe you could fit it in the
trailer but see it again
that was [ __ ] nice motorcycle [ __ ]
tom cruise got one of those
they're worth a lot of money i
i think they're at least a hundred
thousand you guys can check it out but
that's that's a lot for a motorcycle
yeah yeah but it's just i don't know i
really liked the idea of
um you know somebody like like an
autistic character
but like a badass superhero but like i
said it's not like a superhero movie
it's
grounded in reality more or less but
it is kind of like an action thriller
but i thought that was kind of a cool
concept
um so they're talking about and affleck
played batman and daredevil that's right
he did play daredevil at some point
didn't he oh he says he also played
george reeves the guy who played
superman in the old yeah that was in um
hollywoodland right that was actually a
really good movie you probably like that
too it's about george reeves how he died
okay um
yeah i saw it in the theater and i
remember that being really good i'd
forgotten uh ben affleck was in that
somebody they were talking about how
jack affleck got for uh for batman for
batman yeah that was part part of his
[ __ ] douchery was i've seen him on
some of the talk shows and combative and
[ __ ]
dumb and [ __ ]
that's because all that [ __ ] gear
he's on clicking i recognize that i was
like yeah i know that feeling but he's
[ __ ] hacking my ass
like man sorry so are you saying that
you're acting an ass all the time yeah
sometimes that
all that [ __ ] testosterone
shut the [ __ ] up dude
but that's just yeah and it makes you
wonder why berthold is it doesn't get
big okay
he's kind of small
in this movie he looked at him
but i think it kind of works for him to
be honest uh he kind of walks around
kind of bowed up like he's really gonna
do something i'm looking at him i go man
they do small compared to me yeah but
proportionally he's probably a few
inches taller than me
but
i liked that scene with him and that
that dude in the car where they were
having a conversation that that was kind
of like his introduction like as a
character where he was just
beating the crap out of that dude that
was like [ __ ] pretty [ __ ] funny
and like i said well the thing about it
i liked this because everybody in this
is kind of like
i don't want to say everybody's likable
because there are villains but
everybody's a very very morally gray
character like even ben affleck's
character you know not only does he do
accounting like do the books for you
know terrorists like they said he worked
for the taliban and stuff like that
but he's also killed people now granted
the people he killed are usually are bad
people like people from crime families
and [ __ ] like that so i don't think
anybody's going to cry about it but
you know he's still like a criminal
essentially and his brother is too but
they're still like i don't know i guess
they're still kind of like good dudes
though rick shaw says i just saw
bernthal in an interview looks like he's
aged a lot really funny because he's
young he's younger than me by a good six
years
yeah i thought he was young i haven't
seen him in a while see here's the thing
about these guys
all these actors
you're only seeing them on screen
and you're seeing them when they're at
their best when they're [ __ ] trained
up and they're ready to do these roles
same thing with uh
musicians and performers you don't
really know how they live
i mean they might be sucking substance
abusers in all kinds of terrible diet or
so yeah when they don't have to like get
their [ __ ] together for a role or
whatever they might just be like [ __ ]
i'm getting i'm just hitting the doors
[ __ ] doing drugs a lot of them are
drug addicts you know i mean you look at
[ __ ] madonna and what she's done to
herself
madonna's not that old she shouldn't
need all that plastic surgery in her
face little nips and tucks here and
there but she looked like she really
[ __ ] herself up and you're like damn
she didn't age too well she's not that
old you don't know how much that [ __ ]
drinks she might drink a lot she might
do a lot of drugs she might be an addict
yeah you don't really know what's going
on behind the scenes because like you
said you only see them in the movies
when they are at their peak and like
they're shot nice and stuff like that
yeah
and you don't know what they're so you
have this idealized image in your head
well my [ __ ] must work out all
the time oh man he must be real healthy
yeah for that movie when he when he
wasn't working that [ __ ] might
be smoking crack
you just don't know because what time do
you do i get that because i mean the
jobs that they're doing like on the
movies um you know it's very intense a
lot of times depending on what kind of
movie it is obviously but it's very
intense they have to look a particular
way they have to weigh a particular
thing if it's you know an action star
you have to like bulk up you know so
they have like this really like training
regime that they have to do and then
they shoot the movie and it's like two
three months something like that yeah
and then you know they might have
another few months off before their next
project yeah so they're just probably
like [ __ ] that that was like i had to
[ __ ] eat nothing and yeah you had to
do that so it's like they just want to
relax i get that there's only a certain
select few core dudes where working out
and doing that [ __ ] is in them
you know who they are you reckon jason
statham he's into that [ __ ] the rock
that [ __ ] you he wherever he
goes he carries his own gym with him and
it's a it's a tent that's
air-conditioned with a full [ __ ] gym
wherever he goes that thing goes with
him well and he started out as a
wrestler not an actor
and then you got stallone stallone
[ __ ] works out man and he's always
[ __ ] jacked and for an old dude man
[ __ ] stallone is [ __ ] fantastic
and the same with [ __ ]
well
arnold for a while you know um when he
started getting to his 50s his heart
[ __ ] up and he he really couldn't
train that hard
but uh which
stallone
eventually beat him because i think
stallone
didn't go on any gear until he was much
older
than you know [ __ ] arnie was born
taking steroids she was basically he's
[ __ ] 14 [ __ ] doing anavar and
winstrol and [ __ ] getting huge
so
he really burned up a lot of gas in his
tank but jason stanton my [ __ ] works
out [ __ ] the rock [ __ ] rick shaw
said i think statham was an olympic
swimmer before acting yeah yeah so they
were athletes prior they're athletes
before so guys that have athletic or
military backgrounds who are just into
that [ __ ] that's just how they want to
live like whenever i wasn't in training
i felt like [ __ ] like i was cheating
you know getting back into physicality i
feel so much better man i feel a lot
better
looking i just had to be working or
something and but i didn't really lift
up until i guess about four years ago
when i started it makes it's a lot
easier you can [ __ ] really
change your body composition with weight
than just putting on rucksacks walking
around or [ __ ] doing hard labor it's
not the same
tyler the guy says uh he meaning ben
affleck also sleeps with diane lane in
hollywood land so that means batman
slept with superman's mom
[Laughter]
stronghold 78 said this could be a whole
game six degrees of superhero incest
[ __ ] now back what i was saying [ __ ]
uh bernthal he needs to [ __ ] do
something
yeah he needs to do something well like
i said i haven't seen him in a while i
haven't i probably haven't seen him
since last punisher
um have i seen him in anything since
then although when was the last when was
the last punisher
season oh man because this was 2016.
yeah
i'm pretty sure the last 2016 this movie
was yeah that's small then
uh i think there's three or four seasons
of the punisher i got into season two i
can't remember season two seemed to be a
little bit better than season one
but i still just couldn't really stick
with it it was just kind of boring
it's just
but his
the material they gave him in [ __ ] uh
um
in daredevil season two is just spot on
that's that's the [ __ ] punisher
the series is just too
lightweight it's just it's not violent
enough
you know that's
sorry the [ __ ] punisher was a bad guy
basically
hugo says talking about this movie uh
how about when jay jonah jameson played
by jakey simmons says he was a good
father great performance i love that guy
i mean um that was one of his strongest
roles i've seen yeah i mean he's in
[ __ ] he's in [ __ ] everything that
dude is but yeah i really really liked
him in this and honestly i really liked
because you know i don't want to spoil
too much about the movie but a lot of
the
a lot of the people in it like a lot of
the players in it like have backs they
they each kind of get their own
backstory and a lot of things are kind
of like interrelated that you initially
don't think are interrelated like at
first it's interesting that they kind of
have uh in one of the first scenes they
have ben affleck you know um well it's
not ben affleck actually but it's like
somebody playing his character as a kid
and uh he's putting together a puzzle
except he's putting it together like
upside like face down you know what i
mean so he can only see the back but he
knows how to put it together and it's
interesting that they use kind of like
puzzle pieces as a sort of thematic
thing like throughout the movie because
that's kind of how the movie is shot
it's just like all these little random
puzzle pieces
that don't
when you first start watching the movie
it doesn't really make sense how they
fit together until you keep watching it
and then like more connections kind of
come into it so i thought that was like
a clever kind of way to go about it and
it wasn't real overt that that's what
they were doing tyler says there are two
seasons of the punisher when put when
pun when season two dropped we knew it
was only a matter of time because all
the other marvel shows got canceled by
that point okay
i thought i i'd only seen half of season
two i never watched it
it was just to me it was weak sauce
it just seemed weak sauce it wasn't bad
but it wasn't great
dialogue [ __ ] in that in that
character is [ __ ] critical
you can't have [ __ ]
you can't have the [ __ ] partner
walking around [ __ ] saying the kind
of things that he's [ __ ] saying to do
the kind of things that he's doing i
mean the punisher is like what you saw
in daredevil season two
you gotta be saying you're a half
measure he's gonna be punking other
people out he's a vigilante he's killing
people
you know
uh and you're you can't make that a hero
in today's
thing he's an anti-hero
you know he's putting people on meat
hooks and that that's what the punisher
was like so yeah
well and the thing about it i mean kind
of tying back into this movie is that
the characters in this like ben
affleck's character in this he's not a
good guy no he does terrible things and
he's a criminal yeah but
you can root for him but you can still
root for him though i mean evil yeah
he's not an evil person he does have a
moral code right now that was the same
thing with the punisher right
and like i said i do kind of feel like
people uh that's one thing that i kind
of like about more modern movies is that
i think people are a lot more um
open to watching something about an
anti-hero like and somebody that's
obviously not a good guy but
they're still like a compelling
character you don't have to think
they're a good person to want to watch
some [ __ ] right and
for me the punisher is a demon in hell
punishing other [ __ ] demonic sinners
that's what that story is about he's a
he's a bad but he's punishing people
even worse you know that kind of stuff
yeah and he's kind of in his own private
hell
and he has to do this bad [ __ ]
and there's other
depending on what story it is a bunch of
[ __ ] happens in there you know but the
whole head injury angle beautiful that
was [ __ ] great writing that the skull
represented the [ __ ] his head injury
that that was his superpower
yeah been there done that yeah well
yeah
tom said injuries also
says peacemaker is an awesome comic book
tv series james gunn knows how to do
them right which uh streaming service is
that on because i don't know
if i've seen that i don't think i've
seen that
uh yeah tyler guy says the punisher is
pretty much a heroic serial killer yeah
i mean in some ways
he's like a less likable dexter
yeah or [ __ ] hannibal lecter if you
look go to hannibal rising the very
first movie which is masterpiece well
actually the prequel animal rising if
you guys haven't seen it see it [ __ ]
great yeah we're like the batman begins
of serial killer movies
and it's european
done well period piece great sets
good acting great writing yeah good
movie artistic
and it's aged very well
aged very well
rickshaw says bring back dolph lundgren
although how old is that [ __ ] oh
he tool these two
2012 for the punisher they'd have these
they'd have some cgi yeah
i don't know that wasn't a good
punishment movie uh yeah i remember not
really liking it i've only seen it once
and it was a long time ago but i
remember just not it being not all the
time
nailed it in this in [ __ ] season two
of daredevil that's that's it
i kind of feel like daredevil i don't
know i wanted to say that daredevil was
overall my favorite of like the marvel
ones but i don't know jessica jones was
really good oh yeah cage was really good
yeah luke cage was good too i don't know
i liked those three yeah you know the
other one i could have done without iron
fist that was kind of that was kind of
blah but um you know but yeah daredevil
was great jessica jones was great luke
cage was great yeah but uh yeah those
are all i wouldn't mind like re-watching
those at some point
i think we've i think we've rewatched we
watched daredevil like a couple of times
but i think i've only watched jessica
jones like three once daredevil was the
strongest one actually
yeah i mean like i said they were all
good and they all i just i liked them
all for different ways i liked that they
had their own [ __ ] going on season two
with kingpin
[ __ ] that guy who played [ __ ] what
was his baby healy from [ __ ]
yeah
knocks that out of the park one of the
best protectors uh vincent uh vincent uh
d'onofrio yeah i love that actor
that's that's
[ __ ] beautiful acting man [ __ ] his
kingpin where he's
he's a villain but you you sympathize
with him he felt love for that woman and
just that was his day it was just yeah
that was a great see but that's what i
mean it's like even villains i mean your
villain
that's kind of like the linchpin of your
whole
[ __ ] if you don't have a good villain
you don't really have a good story and
the villain has to be complicated just
as complicated as the good guy yeah
because otherwise it's not interesting
right you know what i mean yeah villains
are always kind of more interesting than
good yeah if he's sympathetic it's even
better
yeah like if you can kind of see just
like yeah i could kind of see myself
doing that even though like
intellectually you know it's terrible
but yeah i just think that's really good
but yeah so i think that that
this movie kind of has i don't even know
if like when they made this movie it
almost seemed like they were trying to
set up like a born identity style like
franchise maybe i don't really know um
but i don't i don't know if they're
gonna do that or if they're gonna do any
more of these because this actually did
make quite a bit of money but
i don't know i just like that i liked
the idea of doing sort of a born
identity thing but
with like an autistic mathematician guy
and i don't know i just thought that was
kind of like a cool idea and uh you know
i and i probably wouldn't have watched
it if louis hadn't sent it to us right
because like i said louie always sends
us good movies
right he's got a good reputation i mean
all y'all that send us movies send us
good movies but um i know if it comes
from louie or [ __ ] or or or or if it
comes from louis i know it's going to be
good
if same thing with sophie sophie says
watch this that because she knows you
real well so because we talk all the
time a lot of things so
we have similar tastes in [ __ ]
stories and [ __ ] so she watch this one
and uh man she turned me onto some
[ __ ] good movie she's the one that
sent us the uh that bronson yeah
yeah with uh
which was awesome yeah
i loved that yeah and if you've seen
clockwork orange first then you really
enjoy bronson because it evokes a lot
from
stanley kubrick's [ __ ] clockwork
orange yeah big time yeah
all right so we don't talk about the
accountant all right so either tonight
we will find another movie to watch i
don't know what it's gonna be or
uh we might just watch the other two
because i started watching that john
wayne gacy thing that's on netflix but i
just watched we watched this movie and
then i watched like the first episode of
that and i was too tired to like
stay awake anymore so i don't know so we
might just talk about the john wayne
gacy show or i might find another movie
to watch we'll see what my mood is like
in a couple of hours so we will be back
uh tomorrow talking about another movie
or possibly a series so thanks for
dropping by everybody and we will talk
to you guys again tomorrow